before we start the show thanks so much
for being here at La Rose credit calm
slash mug Club is $99 a year 65 for
students veterans active military that's
how you support the show you get access
to the entire daily show the whole plays
catalog but I also want to let you know
that we are hiring you can go to
laterals credit.com slash jobs we've
been doing this golden ticket
sweepstakes for a while we still have
some room now for some editors and some
people assist in assisting assistants
assisting with booking guests and some
technical work here at the office so
maybe that's you probably not but it
could be ladder with credit comm slash
jobs thank you
this is us giving back but not to to
very small percentage Lauder with
Crowder studios protected exclusively by
Walter and hopper
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes that's called the orbit Spencer's it
has a little electricity like it looks
slightly like the cover of weird science
wonderful four months allowance well
spent but before we get to Gavin McInnes
in the show today we are going to be
talking about the five top times that
social justice warriors have cannibalize
their own and lemma SNL recently won a
couple of questions do you what do you
think of leftist who still insist that
canceled culture doesn't exist it's not
a thing right how far do you think left
a couple acknowledge it secondly why
have none of you fat shamed me this is
important okay yes I need to lose 15
pounds and I got him seriously come on I
want you to fat shame me to motivate me
I got on the scale well I'm getting
really big buddy why didn't anyone tell
me we insult you another way wait can we
give out a reward to like the best fatty
that'd be good yes in war to the best
fat Shamer yes and it was precisely 13
half-asian where bill Richman is with me
today and three how are you quarterblack
garrett is you gene Morgan Jr what's the
one of the day not Gerald Lee one of the
day is realm Fidelio what does that even
mean realm I don't know but it was in a
movie if you can name that well I should
know it the show kicking us off had a
Gatsby remember her she was a creative
arts Emmy for Outstanding writing and
variety or somebody special for Nanette
and she wrote this in accepting the
award she's newsy in accepting the award
oh no that's not her doesn't remind
reading a different quote she just says
if you found strength in the net know
that our stories matter all humanity
matters okay whatever you say mister
it's important the net actually be got a
crowded field of nominees this year for
outstanding writing a comedy special
including HBO's chair noble Peter
Jackson's they will not grow old and
that grainy black and white Holocaust
footage you were forced to watch
yourself more years so it did face some
stout competition like wow
silver crowd deprecation is
self-humiliation
yes it was something just not comedy
this is another thing that's happening
the pornography website bangbros hmm
that's a website has been in ten million
dollars for the naming rights an arena
in Miami
the company said that it wishes to call
the venue the bang center yeah so creepy
at another what I love is he stuttered
there he did seven hundred twenty
million seven and you think oh he's
going to correct himself and instead he
just the pebbles dance wow people talk
about like like Donald Trump yes a
Dayton instead of Toledo you can throw a
baseball from Toledo and hit Dayton Joe
Biden makes up stories and ever happened
in places that don't even exist with
people he's never a scorned pop man the
problem seven and twenty million jobs
use they're only three hundred twenty
seven million people in the United
States aim to the fence of course listen
this isn't the first time that Joe come
on Joe
way well it actually gets worse Stephen
there's only one hundred and sixty five
million women right United States so
he's like wait wait no no no no but
there is actually seven hundred twenty
million women in the Western Hemisphere
over the age of twelve which is his
Democrats very then you've gotten to a
number that's clearly on his mind
because if you don't include this
you'll have a rounding error of point
zero to five speaking of fingers that
don't matter
Andrew yang is a obviously 2020 Kennedy
he's under fire right now from Vox for
using Asian stereotypes they claim the
reinforced toxic tropes and actual
quotes Yang's comments about Asians
being doctors and liking math has some
voters concerned they reinforce
long-standing racist stereotypes refer
to the comments overblown with cores
most vocal critics saying that he
actually has a history of this yang even
pointing to his most recent campaign
slogan of me China me no dumb which
seems like yeah that's it's pandering um
he's steering right into it look if
you're trying to be a racist jerk
calling people smart is not the best way
to do it if frequently people are just
always looking to me for all the answers
then they assume you know things you
don't ever offend you and people assume
that you're good at math um no no I mean
no I don't know math it's not
inconvenient it's actually funny right
because there there is like if when I
look at what the joke is it's someone
who's making a joke that's saying common
ground we have this joke and the joke
exists and they're not saying it as a
joke at me or about me specifically as
an individual it would be a stretch for
me to have taken that personally and
defended instead of just laughing along
with it right douve into that one well
that's deep thank you Bill proving that
Charlie can't take a joke say that
thinness in another way that's important
we time with the SNL thing you know that
he's used the word he used the word is a
word and I want to be really clear that
the word he used because when you read
the articles they say he used the c-word
that's not the c-word using that's not
at all obviously it's not good to call
someone you shouldn't do I don't never
just say it to you I mean what's worse
if you were gonna call them [ __ ] I mean
I know it's too far bill now call me I
think it's important to note words now
with giving them so much power you read
these articles seaward of them no no
it's not it's a different word okay
switching to international news actually
priests air bombed Russians oh that was
my other question of the day that was
where the question Andrew yang was
supposed to be on the show said he would
be and
you are still invited Oh after that
sequence but only if you can do this
matter on material come on cousin yang
hey like to see Andrew yang on the show
let him know yes so we would love those
we would let me know which Democratic
candidate you would like to see most in
the show we have open invitations to all
of them I wouldn't hold my breath
switching an international news Russian
priests they they air bombed with holy
water this area too right I think you
know what here's here's a clip of what
they were doing
curcumin 70 liters worth not a lot of
holy water to promote sobriety in Russia
and it doesn't really sound like a lot
until you see the the aftermath of the
incident yeah but at least he received
final absolution oh good yeah there are
worse things that can happen when
religious fanatics get their hands on a
plane yeah they don't remember 9/11 do
you know know what's missing there is
that they actually celebrated getting
rid of the 7 liters of water by drinking
vodka yeah exactly right look I think
it's gonna take a little bit more than a
75 people died in Russia from drinking
cologne because they thought it had
drinkable alcohol in it something more
than sprinkling water absolutely
confusing cologne and Odin la LDR and it
was not Russian people it was Caucasian
of March cos most dangerous talk in the
world also international news of Barska
and you will understand what I'm telling
the Canadian Cancer Society they're
using a transgender woman on their
cervical cancer people have not been
happy that an actual quote is if you had
vaginoplasty there's a very small risk
that you can develop cancer in the
tissues of your neo vagina or neo
servant I don't necessarily know what
that means parently vagina is the one
this isn't the the first controversy of
its kind that we've covered these
especially with the woman of the year
cover with caitlyn jenner playboy got
into some hot water for the
transgendered pictorials and of course
the outrage over the most recent cover
of yeast infection monthly which seems
as though yeah mm-hmm that's Gerald
seaward Gerald yeah well no not really
you don't you don't make a living off
this notes I drank that bottle down
maybe I know hey there you go it's time
actually for this week's eye on India
[Music]
now that may not make sense were you why
is it pinkeye in India mmm let me tie
this together for you real quick
[Applause]
this week India held its first-ever
national farting contest
sorry the sound vice thank you for doing
the Lord's work
yes surprise the 4:8 reporting 400
million dollars by Disney well spent yes
there's a quote from I guess the person
putting on the farting contest to
normalize the natural body process
prizes are being given to those whose
farts are the loudest longest and most
musical hmm most yeah most musical which
I you know this may sound weird us you
can chuck up to cultural differences the
idea that a fart could be musical but
when you actually see the winner of the
contest it's pretty impressive huh
[Music]
a price well Chef Boyardee is amazing
first if I had gas I would put a
competition on like this - I'd be like
honey it naturalizes the body of the
entire country sportsmen have you seen
their tap water lab results I don't
think we have any more on India
[Music]
here's a story could have worldwide
implications Saudi Arabia obviously you
know about this presented evidence that
Iran was behind the the oil attacks
though the Defense Ministry this comes
from BBC has shown off what it says is
the wreckage of drones and cruise
missiles steven is that uh is that a new
watch oh yeah it's um I think it's was
it was it called Odom Oh tomorrow
tomorrow's take a it was a gift from a
you know sponsor Mohammed bin Salman but
I'm not really a watch guy oh can I have
it yeah durable I think it's approved up
to a hundred meters finally women are
flocking to plastic surgeons right now
to fix resting [ __ ]
snacks according to one plastic surgeon
it's a common request they may not
always use the words but if I mention
RBF they say exactly oh my god the
surgery of course has been called an
artist with the human faces canvas and
he's most celebrated for RBF work on our
BG AOC the notorious b.i.g and medical
anomaly the RBF elephant woman so you
know that's seamless terrible oh my gosh
this is a quick turnaround like reading
this story is like it's hilarious
because smiling is that difficult that
you would have surgery to not be sorry
I'm sorry changes you on the outside I'm
sorry I wouldn't say you're such a [ __ ]
that you can't smile to not look like a
[ __ ] when you know you look like a
[ __ ] it's the [ __ ] lap-band exactly
there's there's no beautiful face
without the RBF right there's no
sweetness our
yes there really is no don't need it by
the way what's the square root of 492
yeah seventy-nine thousand million
you're not a math railroads are nails
Asia alright so listen have to take a
quick take a quick here's it go back
into court office a quick kind of detour
here there is supposed to be a sketch
today that involved a clown in the
office and I think yeah this is b-roll
up here yeah you can just show it yeah
this was a clown in the office that we
shot where the clown got stabbed hit
with a bottle okay that's a long time to
tape this but we had costume we had
makeup we had a sketch right nothing
that we wrote are created could possibly
be funnest this was funnier so we axed
it and we replaced it with this security
camera from the office 10 p.m. last
night
this is Brendon our brilliant editor
he's doing backup vocals for the Nirvana
song if he could come in here Brandon
let's bring in even Brendon here
brilliant editor wonderful guy Brendon
written come on in ok can you can you
tell me for a second what were you what
were you doing you climbed up and then
you were gone well put a brian Stelter
head on the ceiling just we found it
yeah
is that 40 feet up mmm overestimated
Lizbeth it's got to be like 20 at least
Noah 40 yeah here's my question did you
come in with the express purpose of
doing that like did you say I'm gonna go
in and work on my vocals or you say I'm
gonna go in and climb a pole he was
inspired which which by the way is
incredibly impressive but wildly
dangerous you're aware that's right yes
there's no grip on that pole if you've
been seen so actually sign this yeah
yeah liability waiver got to be really
firm yeah there goes your insurance
mm-hmm you think we're joking but bill
actually drafted this up if you fall
yeah if you fall putting a brian Stelter
you know if you get had me 40 feet up
yeah you have to cover your insurance
all you yeah okay Thank You Brendan we
appreciate good by the way the vocals
weren't bad
they were good I mean with heart for
screaming when I asked him if we could
have him on air he was more concerned
about the vocals thing I still work Oh
like I was pitchy there's a surgery for
that oh my gosh yes two hours later that
the the Mike made a beep accidentally
because I was trying to look and what
beat he stops and goes John are you
watching again he is crazy farmer
strength he's from Wisconsin like that
is amazing all right by the way last
week on before we move on to the meat
segment last week's trivia contest
winner is a metal gunner at metal gun
correctly you correctly answer that
Bernie Sanders thought breadlines
or a good thing alright so uh let's move
on to this segment here the top five
examples of
sjw's or just let's just call them
leftist now because I think that's sjw
is a flagged word on your piece yeah
yeah if you put sjw in YouTube you're
immediately demonetised yeah so let's
use this as a jumping off point SNL they
dropped a new cast member Shane Gillis
right if you haven't followed this will
talk about Gavin next this was following
some social media out
based on some jokes they said he
wouldn't be joining the cast jokes and
his comments were quote offensive
hurtful and acceptable to the Asian
community proving once again that
Charlie can't take a joke bill can you
actually know that no Asians were
offended by the jokes right it was just
white people
we're on behalf ATS on behalf of Asians
because all the agents were laughing
right yeah it was a guy from Vox or vice
or whoever it was who does the spoken
bird poetry but you know it's good to
know that SNL that's not a joke sperm
spoken both good thing to know that the
SNL drop draws the line at Asian jokes
joining us now are three peasant
laborers from the factory in China where
these iPhones were manufactured oh
you're upset with the bug 220 bug in for
Nia
I sleep in communal bunk bed with
hundred stranger lice okay it's just one
racist for baby formula by the way I
actually thought the sketch was funny I
thought the sketch was funny that's 2014
just so you know it's not like you have
to dig that line through and go back to
Rob Schneider or have to go back to
breakfast at tiffany's sorry it was the
70s that's basically the last cast
member who was replaced by the other
black female cast member who was
replaced by the other black female cast
member huh just never I think we do need
to make sure to appropriately punish all
of the audience members who laughed yes
that's that joke okay by the way now as
you missed it here's the controversial
clip from the person they asked in
question so you can see them damn
Chinatown's [ __ ] nuts it's crazy this
is full [ __ ] China I wonder how that
started they just built one fucked-up
looking building and people are like all
right no one said anything let's live
there I mean it's not I don't think it's
funny but no but here's here this is an
isolated incident the mob is going to
come after comics celebrities
politicians regardless of out woke they
are and that's why I want to cycle
through five examples of the most woke
people we can think of leftist folks
then had the crocodiles turn on them so
example number five Sarah Silverman this
is important after Kevin Hart memory was
fired from the Oscars for homophobic
tweets that they dug through she didn't
come to his defense and she said that
she was done making gay jokes and she
likened the use of the word gay to
racism more like find a way friends I
just say gay and then I heard myself and
I realized I was like the guy who said
what I say colored I have colored
friends isn't always great at this
revelation comes after they've made
their tens of millions of dollars right
exactly my Beverly Hills mansion and
think about what I've done
during a 97 hour spot before in other
ways everything was everything was a
shock comic joke oh she had wreck-it
Ralph and it's like I just now I'm now I
get it
now I understand now if I sleep on a bed
of million dollars any comedians
comedians are doing this at all yeah of
course they should be whether they agree
with it or not they should be
championing free speech that's what's so
concerned to me this is a shock comic
who climbed a ladder and then pulled it
up and is now pelting other comedians
with paintballs I guess I don't know
what she would you she was not gonna
have a gun no it's not a gun it's a nerf
gun and so what happened she found
herself being canceled for doing a skit
in blackface you're talking about it I
recently was gonna do it movie two days
on a movie a really a sweet part in a
cool little movie and then at 11 p.m.
the night before they fired me because
they saw that pay a picture of me and
blackface from that episode person
anymore
but I was doing it you know I didn't go
to a Halloween party in the 80s in
blackface I was doing an episode about
race you know now I understand it's
never okay and blah blah blah
number one spot is the most woke person
you can think of who did go in blackface
not once but
right and sang the banana song well and
Tom here's the thing she accidentally
she accidentally stumbled upon truth in
the earlier part of that interview where
she said her response to the question
about it was comedians don't like to be
told what to do but then she's like I
can't be really clear I don't think she
should have been cancelled or punished
oh no blackface sketch was about a girl
who was tone-deaf doing blackface to
impress black you write funny sketch I
think seriously women can be very funny
at times and I am not advocating for her
to be canceled at all I'm pointing out
the standard by which they want to be
judged yeah I think conservatives need
to be really careful about this we
shouldn't be advocating that anyone else
could can't oh we should be pointing out
their standards but then we should be
defending them and championing their
right to do these things to say these
things and not be canceled and I'm not
just talking about First Amendment and
we talk about this all the time at First
Amendment obviously it's government
nobody ever management but we are
talking about a culture right now of
bullying people into silence and art is
just as important okay example number
four this might surprise you Lena Dunham
you know I've talked about her dead
drawers in your vagina's she's the
creator HBO the woke series girls right
and also noted survivor of condoms and
potted plants she's she's effectively
the SJW brave feminist archetype right
she won awards for support of the LGBTQ
community she campaigned for Obama and
Clinton she pledged to moved to Canada
if Trump wouldn't only boiler alert she
didn't and she badly made a big deal out
of activism to fight sexual assault she
talked about being raped by a guy named
Barry the resident Republican at her
college and then she did this whole PSA
I think we have a clip yeah PSA about
sexual assault yeah and one in four
girls will be sexually abused before the
age of 18 this isn't a secret but not
the one in the party so why is our
default reaction as a society to
disbelieve or to silence all to shame by
the way it's important to remember they
did the the one in five women are raped
right and they said one in four women
are raped means one in four women are
sexually assaulted it's not true no it's
not a true no Dalida Bob do you look at
the bureau of justice if you look at the
FBI statistics it's just not factually
accurate it is a number though and until
her wage rate was low and the editors of
her memoir actually had to change the
book after threats of legal access so
there's the argument in the court of
public opinion and then there's all
right we have to pull it when it gets
legal right Francisco
and just yank it no problem let's uh if
this is the tool that we're using
canceling then we wonder when you let
the tiger loose comes back and bite you
tiger another reference to Charlie I'm
seeing him in there it's like a shuck
and jive and round this is not a stirs
bro
it's like dodging a wrench one of the
funniest things ever seen in that book
vivid descriptions of sexually abusing
your little sister yeah okay
hooting spreading your said bull if you
have kids leave the room spreading her
sisters vagina open when she was 11 or
she her sister was 11 and she is 17
bribing her with with candy to kiss her
on the lips masturbating in bed next to
her this is the lena Dunham's own words
she wrote anything a sexual predator
might do to woo a small suburban girl I
was trying so I guess it's not so much
canceled culture as it is sick twisted
Hamsi older sister culture but that's
not even what bothered the woke cancel
lists I guess that's what we'll call
them yeah that's good it was the
hypocrisy that she had him than me to
move it I think you had you know no no
no I mean that that's not the kind of
beautiful and brave thing that we're
looking for right so that the the joke
that we make about it obviously some
people are they have to fight through a
lot of different tragedies in their life
or whatever that they're feeling that's
not it
assaulting your sister she can't be all
do stuff no no no no so the argument was
that she was 7 years old when she
started her sister was one sexually
molest your your little snow I hit my
brother with a shovel but I never never
never raped never also hit audio Wade
with a shovel I think we all have
actually this shows you where the
priorities are the cancel they didn't
care about that they cared about her
epoxy on than me to movement right so
right this producer of the show girls
was accused of raping a 17 year old girl
and then Lena Dunham responded without
any evidence of the girl was lying this
is her her statement while our first
instinct is to listen to every woman's
story because you demanded that they do
the incest knowledge of Murray situation
makes us confident that sadly this
accusation is one of the 3% of assault
cases that are missed reported every
year first off the only three percent
that are missed reported record
allegations and you didn't
negation they're marching about the
Cavanaugh investigation would write
thorough as you could possibly make it
because someone sent something to the
FBI at some point that wasn't
corroborated and she's going even though
this guy was accused of rape
we don't think he dead really why not
yeah he said no it's not misreporting
it's lying so we know that went from
believe all women to now this guy's
making it up without even looking any
evidence and by the way this is what
finally led to the social justice words
calling her Dunham's cancellation it's
hard not to be happy about this example
culture but you know I I'm also against
raping sisters yeah yeah the the biggest
thing she actually got pissed off that
people thought she was a sexual predator
when she described herself as a sexual
predator
right and gave it's like Jerry Sandusky
saying yeah I know I had sex with that
kid in the in the shower and you guys
saw me but that doesn't make me a bad
guy I'm not a pedophile it's almost like
a Twitter personality from a certain
things on his Twitter handle and then
the list of people who want to hurt me
it's a long one number three Chris Evans
Chris Evans is about as woke as you can
get for a white guy he's called Donald
Trump a racist and he's been headlining
LGBTQIA ap events to pushing abortion
without any restrictions whatsoever
which which by the way it should be
completely out of line considering the
penis I thought it was no uterus no
opinions logic bring your cut right in
sir let's give up Essential buddy so him
and his co-star Jeremy Renner they made
the mistake of calling Black Widow
referring to Black Widow a fictional
character mind you as a [ __ ] she's with
Bruce what what are you guys making
jesus lud
[Laughter]
talking about a cartoon care yes yeah
talk to me is an involuntary action yeah
he thought that was funny gentleman well
it's not this so when we talk about
gender or society condition no telling
someone that they shouldn't find
something that's taboo or offensive
funny
that's your attempt at social
engineering right laughs that's a
guttural response that is this is funny
and you want to tell him that his
emotive reaction is wrong and of course
he apologized evidence apology was we
answered in a very juvenile offensive
way that rightfully angered some fans I
regret it and I sincerely apologize I'm
sorry that this tasteless joke about a
fictional character offended anyone
thank you thank you threw a little dig
in there this joke about an offensive
character I'm like seriously you just
sort of said these people were stupid
bill like if you love life if you were
advising one of these people today would
you tell them to apologize like that for
something that is absolutely so non
offensive to anybody I mean it's not
really down you it's not really a legal
issue it's a question of where you're
gonna draw it smart its PR and in you
know what the funny part is I like what
you're pointing there is that if you
read it and you emphasize the words of
him reading although I'd be like if
everyone's offended at this comment
about a fictional yeah terror character
then I apologize I apologize that you're
that dumb I'm waiting for somebody to
stand up to it when it's really very
similar to the fictional character
involved with lena Dunham's rape example
number two Aziz Ansari so he should be
an expert by the way a navien hole woke
male-female relationship he was the
little brown feminist that could your
feminist if you go to a jay-z and
Beyonce concert and you're not like I
feel like Beyonce should get 23 percent
less money than jay-z also I don't know
if they should have the right to vote
wrong I don't know anyone who says that
nobody I know gay guys who use the term
Queen Bee and then I a new guy I always
found that I found out that you know how
I found out the term queen bee was a
thing because I heard a bunch of gay
guys saying queen bee and then I heard a
guy who claimed you a straight say queen
bee as an
but no now I know it turns out he was
gay yeah your gaydar was that I don't
either proof other than he said queen
bee but take a look enough he also wrote
by the way is he's I'm sorry he wrote
this sort of postmodern book and
romantic relationships right and what
did he do as they come for him to he
committed the unforgivable crime of
going on a date with a girl that didn't
go so well
so for those of you who are confused bad
date is now a synonym for sexual
misconduct
apparently keep in mind we're not
advocating for casual sex here or
promiscuity where the Conservatives were
mocked for advocating abstinence until
marriage but ladies let me just say this
okay if you're going to a guy's
apartment okay and you strip down to
nothing and you start engaging in sex I
don't want to I don't want to say that
you're asking for it but that's because
oh because you're already doing it yeah
you asked for it really I got it you
were doing it and then you didn't want
it like chance and homeward-bound with
the porcupine but the it what is the it
that is the point yeah what do you do
now I mean like seriously as a guy if
you're I again we would advise you the
best advice got even better now
abstinence until your marriage that's
better advice but what do you do as a
guy now a woman gets naked and starts
doing things to you well I'm sorry I
don't know you they had sex
laters yeah she's later said it was rape
because when she woke up so she talked
about alcohol and muscle relaxers right
right she peed in the parking lot that I
got Blin and she talked about going back
having sex with them but waking up the
next day and noticing a condom was in a
potted plant so he said it's clear to me
that I asked him to wear the condom and
he took it off midst of you don't know
when the condom came on yeah you also
don't know if you asked him to wear the
condom you were both completely
inebriated now does that mean that he
didn't harass you does that no it does
but you also to love for the possibility
that you made bad decisions it's not the
same as aggravated rape yeah and by the
way I think the guys who specifically
target women who are drunk especially if
they're sober are germs you should stay
away from them but it was not that kind
of a scenario want to be really clear
here too I don't think the disease I'm
sorry should be canceled I'm not
advocating that for any of these people
but they will come free okay example
number one this one is just I love ya
my favorite people the darling of the
left Prime Minister of Canada Justin
Trudeau remember this is the guy who
broke down in tears apologizing to the
two-spirit community I didn't even like
I didn't know it was a real I thought I
was a Halloween store yeah no fools in
October spirit so everyone does have
skeletons in their closet even the guy
who apologizes to the two-spirit
community but yesterday Time magazine or
earlier this week they dropped the
funniest story of all time that is
awesome I mean that is very I mean it's
technically brown face yes so that's
black please dress all white it's
hilarity we shoe polish we all know
exactly brilliant what a mocha I thought
it was the actual color we talked about
black Indians especially South Indians
can be a far darker than black people
it's not an accurate descriptive true I
just want to be clear racism not
advocate I don't think he should lose
his reelection but megyn kelly for that
basically canceled for merely suggesting
that someone doing blackface back them
they might not have been inherently
racist I want to contrast the comments
that got megyn kelly cancellous
juxtapose that with Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau's apology here you go
truly you do get in trouble if you are a
white person who puts on a Halloween or
a black person who puts on white face
tornado my piece is fine okay I was a
kid that was okay as long as you were
dressing there's like guys character I
didn't think was racist at the time but
now I recognize it was something racist
to do and I am deeply sorry is that the
only time in your life you've ever done
something like that when I was in high
school I dressed up at a talent show
and sang Dale wait there's more Wow
black face he was positively a black
face he didn't like no one knew about
this and then it didn't happen and he
didn't remember and didn't bother to
tell anyone about actually there's two
but also see on his face when this story
broke and they're asking those questions
like I'm sorry I didn't really I didn't
know that it was racist back then but
now I understand any sitting anything so
it's over and then someone says yes
excuse me is this just the only time you
can see in his head he's going never
come back up but I did in blackface
dress as part of the Jackson 5 and it
wasn't even Michael or Tina oh my gosh
look I love I could have happened to a
nicer guy I am like you like Lena Dunham
on this list in him like I'm kind of
like good I'm glad something like that
happened but it's like they can't
control their own creation and I don't
want it to happen to anybody it just it
tears me apart because I'm like you
deserve it not like this you don't want
them to say I want the best version of
whoever's coming and I want the best
Muhammad Ali who's ever come in that way
there can be no doubt I want to beat
these people on policies and ideas and
it's fun it's fun the hypocrisy is funny
but I gotta say the point has got to be
that we're the whole point of this is
that the ridiculousness of the
quote-unquote punishment yeah Hansol
culture is a as a way to punish they've
let the tiger loose it comes back and
bite them because it they didn't really
think of what the consequences were
what's the consequence of limiting free
speech to only speech that some
particular group happens to be our
approves at them Yeah right and who said
that we say that all the time say hey
this is what these turn back on yeah and
they're like whatever we're gonna do
it's never gonna happen
what the left does with every single
thing we've talked about this before and
it's that we are trying to warn you this
will always hurt you and we do have to
you know go on your neck Gavin McInnes
and we'll talk a little bit more about
SNL I think it's important to note a lot
of people say well you know what I'm not
I'm not Alex Jones right that was when
they canceled Alex Jones and this is one
thing I just realized we're kind of the
only program to have endured an all-out
assault to Beadie platform instead
because you attack after them hard well
they did it with with Milo they did it
with Alex Jones and you know with other
I mean they've done it with people
obviously we're not servants they did it
right here they went after Gavin I think
he's still available on YouTube we'll
talk to him about that um we didn't
apologize because I didn't do anything
wrong we doubled down we didn't just go
back and by the way conservatives don't
don't just complain and say look they're
trying to censor me now I'm back funnier
and harder do not apologize if you
haven't anything wrong Andrew Breitbart
you said apologize for what they're
going to crucify you for something no
matter what so if you feel like you
maybe said something that was on the
line you're not entirely sure and you
think maybe if you apologize it'll go
away remember they went after Sarah
Silverman Lena Dunham Aziz Ansari
Trudeau Chris Evans you haven't got a
shot none of you have a shot they will
go after you no matter what and I want
to make sure that everyone out there
because we've seen a lot of comedians
who used to pinch themselves liberals
who have now come to the other side of
the fence just because of this canceled
culture well there are still some other
comedians saying it's not a real thing
like Andy Kindler he's there's not a
real thing yes okay I bet you will be
talking with him in about six months
jump in the waters warm we will always
be here yeah defending you and
advocating against canceled culture
because I don't want to see it happen to
anybody and then I'll see you on the
other side of that cage with your
policies which I think are stupid and
those should be canceled yeah McGinnis
right after this yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever you want just take it and leave
if you don't leave I will use it I will
shoot what did you expect I am gonna sue
you so hard guilty
what no I I don't understand it I'm
sorry there's nothing I can do
firearms legal.com /lw see if you have a
gun and you don't have this you're an
idiot
again that's firearms legal calm /lw see
hashtag body pride hashtag bad G Gerald
be so beautiful he's never gonna hit a
home run Gerald D he's always good for
fun I didn't claim to be an expert I
didn't claim anything and I also don't
do political content I consider myself a
citizen of the world of humanity and we
all have aligned interests if we're
believing that we are all moving toward
the same path to enlightenment I think
some of us are for the long path what
are you going to be talking about today
- Wednesday yeah top five greatest
television shows of all time I was gonna
say Dukes of Hazzard that's always funny
how them boys gonna get out of this one
I don't watch drama I read you're not
saying that vaping is harmless but that
it is certainly less harmful than
cigarettes and the goal of vaping is to
get people off of cigarettes that's the
argument that I've heard you make and
then I've heard Chris Cuomo say that
you're putting all of our children into
a shallow grave so I don't know who to
believe but I'm gonna give you the floor
I would say never believe a Cuomo it's a
pretty good read all right
[Music]
[Music]
now what is the thing you like that
Dingle tinkle time do my hiding goal
down Dingle down I don't know it's a
very different culture the Australians
Australia you know else is a big
difference in culture who the Chinese
that's our next guest you can go to
defend Gavin come to support him he has
his show at free speech TV though he's
technically an unemployed talk show host
in case you don't know who it is now
Gavin McGuinness how are you sir allows
Stephen how are you I'm okay my voice is
a little bit hoarse but you're you're
looking well hey let me ask you this
have you been following the SNL Shankill
of Steel
I am totally obsessed I actually don't
know shame but we travel in the same
circles and we've been reporting on it
all week today we pooped ourselves when
we watched this old video he did a year
ago August of 2018 where he plays a
fireman who saved this family but the
interviewer discovers that he likes mega
and he used a racial epithet once in a
text to a friend right and so they fire
him and it's exactly what happened in
real life and the craziest part is that
they show his address on the screen and
it's haverford PA mmm-hmm Haverford PA
was the fire department that was shut
down a couple weeks ago because the VP
happened to be a proud boy so video is
too spooky for words so basically what
you're saying is that Shane Gillis is a
probably some kind of an initiation as
has been reported I'm sure he would have
been initiated you know he actually
included if I'm not mistaken I think
Lorne Michaels the spokesperson for SNL
said that was included in his audition
the the Mogga hat firefighter really
yeah he may have adapted it ah would be
business pinned the pinned comment and
it's also a year old on that video says
this is way funnier than SNL yes yes
this is well that's not necessarily hard
to do what's the name of the guy who who
writes for vulture and advice the guy
who outed him
Shane what's his s something do you know
the name he does
Norman Donald wasn't jokingly said
spoken bird poetry the guy who covers
comedy
I can't remember his name we'll bring it
up here's an overlay and he was the one
who broke this story about the racial
epithets and you can go and watch him
doing this alt comedy this is a scene
that developed since I've I've since
been away from the stand-up saying I
can't imagine doing it where they they
perform in libraries and the guy goes up
and performs bird spoken Berto a tree so
there he goes could go eagle eagle that
was a Mockingbird doing an impersonation
of an eagle and it's like okay it's kind
of cute but these all I guess all
turtles let's say alternative comedians
it's 20 minutes of a gag that could have
been funny but they just drag it on too
long and they have nowhere else to go
alt comedy none of these critics could
survive in the arena where they destroy
lies it's it's ironic that they sit
there go cancel culture isn't real he'll
do fine meanwhile if they had even a
flick of what Shane Gillis is getting
they'd be out on their ass I mean they
have patreon these people and you look
at their patreon like Vic burger makes I
think 300 dollars a month by begging so
the only thing more pathetic than
begging is not getting paid yes
it'd be like someone rattling a tin cup
and you knocking it out of his hand
because you heard that he made a racial
episode sometime which really when you
think about it if he's homeless the
racial epithet should be least of your
concern it really adds needles and teach
critique and these critics are all
useless bitter jealous see words I don't
know what why yeah you're that what
you're saying and by the way that was
quoting Shane Gillis no don't try and
divas are what they are
do not blame me speaking of which and
we're going to go to the web extended
afterwards and talk about Brett
Kavanaugh did you watch any of Lily
Singh's new Late Show that's on NBC
replacing Carson Daly okay let me
explain Lily what a lot of these TV
execs don't understand is they see a
successful youtuber and they go oh this
person has a huge audience that will
easily transpose to television right but
they don't understand us a lot of these
guys have huge clear
from little kids like my six-year-old
his favorite show is guava juice his
favorite youtuber and that guy hasn't
that a hard liquor your six-year-old was
drinking mezcal not surprised
no that's the name of his favorite
YouTube oh okay and guava juice talks
like this and he goes hey we're gonna
get in a big bath full of Skittles and
that'll have 20 million views so eerily
axing talks like that she goes oh my
parents are too corny and conservative
oh my gosh they want me to Maddie did
you talk like that her mom does talk
like that and Margaret Cho's mom don't
like that so I can't inherit sir
foreigners what and so she has a huge
following of children and losers and
nobodies and then transpose that same
YouTube Nickelodeon way of talking the
TV and it's just so rehearsed and
embarrassing I get goose pimples on this
part of my body yeah time I get them but
they're they're actually they're not the
term is genital warts but they're
strikingly similar like thing is this
was my penis having sex with geese
lately how long is this last what's the
half-life on the on the goose pimple and
is there here is it just serum goose
pimple or is it like mono where it's
always dormant but it's is it a virus
later he's the genital goose pimples so
here's when I saw this I thought it was
very similar I don't remember when
YouTube started there was a girl named
Lisa Nova and by the way this is
important we go out there because what
they'll do with what they've done with
Gavin what they've done with myself what
they've done with norm by the way and
Dennis Miller and even some people
who've just been on our show they'd lob
the accusation was just not funny
and I heard this on the view this well I
just don't think that was funny listen
he used this he used the word I want to
be clear so we know what we're talking
about he used though it's the c-word
because I seem to writing c-word and I
think it's a different word he used that
but that wasn't the joke he was
referring to people in Chinatown he had
a bunch of other jokes I don't
necessarily think it was funny but I
acknowledge that it was a joke and
people try to separate it from the joke
they separate the offense from the joke
anyway to go back there was this girl
named Lisa Nova who was one of the early
sketch artists they brought her on MADtv
she did a couple of funny impressions
they brought her on MADtv I think she
lasted
and it didn't work because she was
talking to her camera in a bedroom she
didn't know what was like to perform in
front of a live studio audience she
didn't have that experience same thing
with us Lilly Singh she's done videos on
YouTube and kind of showed up and spoken
for her fans but she doesn't have any
experience of the live audience and so I
watched this premiere and I said you
know what that's probably a girl who
would be middle-of-the-pack at an open
mic who just you would say give her five
six years of seasoning let her work it
out but she's not there yet only she's
performing that same material they'll be
mediocre Dan open mic but someone has an
applause sign for the audience and
that's what makes it so uncomfortable
she did a seven minute diatribe on how
terrified we are at the idea of a brown
woman talk-show host
meanwhile she's a Canadian bisexual Sikh
so it's not like we talked about the
threat of the Canadian bisexuals seek
every second day but for seven minutes
she goes I know you're freaking out
you're like hashtag not my Carson Daly
and you go no but I don't care by the
way is anyone that possessive of Carson
Daly you're not gonna take my Carson
from me I feel like it was either him or
the Ron Popeil pocket fisherman rerun it
kept looping into itself until I was
watching or going wait are you making
fun of your own political belief system
because you're not marrying mine yeah
you're making fun of the concept of
someone being terrified the only people
that are terrified are the executives at
NBC when they see these ratings it's
going to be a brutal takedown yeah I
think it's going to probably be pretty
rough but I think it's important to note
that a lot of you don't know what
they're doing right they're saying okay
we want to try and bring a nonlinear
content and they they want to bring in
people from YouTube but they don't
understand necessarily how to make it
work and it is amazing right now that
this discussion who is if someone from
Seth Meyers a black girl is going to
have another late night show oh how many
late nights do you need I don't know but
they go the late night landscape has to
change and they show all the hosts and
I'm looking I'm going okay we got Seth
Meyers we got Trevor Noah we got
Samantha B we got Stephen Colbert and
their argument is look at how
homogeneous this isn't well no law
second you have men
women under-qualified women a lot of
them under-qualified South Africans but
you do have a good in color spectrum
here you don't have a single person
who's even moderate let alone a
center-right and they had no clue there
is ZERO diversity of opinion and she
showed herself with all the talk show
hosts and then she threw in Hasan Minhaj
and her meemaw by the way Muslims killed
a million Sikhs so I don't know why
she's all buddy-buddy with them one
Muslim guy on TV but all of those people
Hasan
Lilly all of the talk shows have exactly
the same as he just said radical leftist
politics there is ZERO diversity of
opinion I mean in this modern landscape
of talk shows if you were Jay Leno and
all Jay Leno did was not hate
Republicans if you were Jay Leno you'd
be David Duke yeah well I think that
says that was his nickname that was his
fighting name it was Jay David dude
letter he switched it from the
chiropractor Jay the chiropractor Leno
no something else though that's
interesting to me is I don't know if you
know this they pre-taped with Lilly
Singh so this is important because it
coincides while this Shane Gillis is
getting cancelled for a joke right for
being what they consider racist let's
call it edgy he's getting removed from
SNL well the same time they're pushing
releasing they pre-taped they said like
30 or 40 of her episodes and they said
we don't want this to be political it's
going to be more personal late-night
show is topical that's a big reason that
it differs from stand-up you're covering
news of the day and then she took shots
at Trump
she took shots at I mean you just look
at you're gonna Hoss they don't consider
this political that's what's crazy they
go it's not gonna be political the
entire first half of the show was you're
afraid of a woman of color and I'm
coming for late-night white man hashtag
me to him what they don't see this is
political you know Lilly Singh is
everything wrong with affirmative action
and firing Brett Gillis is this I mean
what's his name again Shane Gillis yeah
that is everything wrong with
affirmative action - you're getting rid
of a funny dude based on BS and by the
way he never said these Darrent darn
kids are taking our jobs they were
making fun of a type of person and they
said Chinatown just springs up and then
people are like what's all these
buildings here yeah they're like what
are all these chicks here he said people
are like so he was doing a a guy was
freaked out by Chinatown he wasn't using
the word on a personal level but
we get rid of him we get rid of you know
I think Lauren Michaels was going let's
get some actual quality comedy back like
Robert Downey who defined SNL right on
the ease to the 90s they thought let's
get a new Robert Downey this guy seems
kind of centrist maybe he can do some
good jokes they go no and the reason
they attacked him we all know is cuz
he's a white male that's what this is
about Lilly Singh can do no wrong
because she's beige and she's white okay
I have to make sure that distance myself
from this alleged cloud this guy we
prefer the term taupe would you act like
the taupe is the term sand sand like my
2004 Taurus yeah cream yeah cream also
love their their music the black room
with white curtains in the 1960s I don't
know of any other songs from cream can
you give me any other songs from cream
Gavin that were hips cream yeah didn't
they do sunshine of my life was it I
don't think it even snow we don't have
the ability of fact-check that's right
someone get Jamie from Joe Rogan oh yeah
well that's the Nathan Phillips version
all right we're gonna go to a web
extended here for people who miss it and
talk a little bit about the Kavanaugh
controversy those are the only two
topics of the week week it's free speech
TV before we go to web here Gavin
where's the best place for people to
find and support you you can only find
me on free speech TV although I'm on a
bunch of ghetto social media like
telegram and parlor but you can find
those links at free speech TV under
links I hang out at a parlor and so last
place is still called it a parlor Lila
ochio Buckley our previous scarless
Gavin McInnes for a little commercial
break web extended about Mack
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what would you do day one solution
vamos a tratar carcassona
mr. cocky masoukishin or sue Karen oh
gee
Kumar big Presidente attackable demon
asado lost immigrant aces in except
table well
[Music]
[Music]
oh that was a Justin Trudeau I'm singing
Dale underwater but you couldn't you
couldn't tell cuz the black face had
washed off oh darn makeup it wasn't so
much just water as it was a very large
Epsom salt bath hmm so it falls off all
the paint yeah
little-known trick for really you don't
know you want to get the cleanest you'll
ever be in your life take an Epsom salt
bath okay
load up left themselves and then just
rinse off in the shower you will see a
ring around the tub yeah ra's everything
out I don't live in one of those poor
strips from your but you do that
blackface a lot thank you so much
together McGinnis a web extended
interview of course available
exclusively for those who are members at
the blaze and thank you so much for
everyone who's been supporting us lately
we really do appreciate it we know some
of you are waiting on your mugs because
we've been backordered we've had so many
orders come in and I want to make sure I
clarify earlier when we're talking about
how this is the only show that survived
that sort of onslaught of canceled
culture that's not to brag that's really
out of gratitude to all of you guys the
only reason we're able to do this is
because of you and because of people who
join up at mug club if there's if
there's no mug club if you guys don't
join and many of you have and support us
there's enough of you out there to
support what we're doing now we're done
like top do you know do you know how
much we're making on YouTube zero yeah
yeah not any zero we also can't sell
some of our merch yeah although you
can't go to a lot of gutter shop calm
and click the mystery box mystery box
who knows who knows what it is it's not
a date I don't know it's don't are figs
and dates stone fruits or stone fruits
I'm so quite clear what a stone fruit
has a pit they're like cousin fruit yeah
like cousin fruits I wouldn't wreck I
don't I wouldn't know a fake from a date
um all right so a couple things I know
we we often talk about some of our macro
issues here in the in the close this is
one thing that I noticed in talking with
them younger relative I will say I don't
know if I say nice if I say nephew if I
say cousin and I never like it's me and
they're gonna get mad at the parents so
I hear this a lot those prickly in
children's shows and you hear on radio
we're constantly told for as long as I
can remember
certainly our entire upbringing that the
most important thing you can do is
believe in your
right that's the mantra that we hear and
it's usually married with you can
accomplish you can accomplish anything
if you just if you just believe in
yourself it's it's the most important
thing is that you believe in yourself
and then you can accomplish anything you
put your mind to all right I'm here to
tell you that neither of those
statements are true that's not a bad
thing because you know what it's okay
it's okay to be unsure of yourself it's
okay not to know now it's not okay to
let that overtake you to paralyze you to
prevent you from doing the work that has
to be done anyway but it is okay
to be unsure of your abilities here's
something else you can still accomplish
by the way great things without entirely
believing in yourself sometimes your
greatest accomplishments come in an
environment in an incubator of
self-doubt now notice I didn't say self
defeat so I don't want to say people are
telling you to believe in yourself and
you shouldn't believe in yourself at all
that's not what I'm saying
doubt is a very different animal from
defeat doubt is not a guarantee of
failure it's just a healthy skepticism
of this notion that we're taught of a
guaranteed victory because you know what
doubting yourself does you know what
does well if you're a productive person
a person who utilizes critical thinking
you're gonna set out to determine
whether that doubt is valid it's the
absolute confidence to believe in
yourself if you buy that wholesale it
breeds complacency healthy self-doubt
breeds inquiry it breeds vigilance also
something else self-doubt usually only
enters into the equation when it's a
decision of consequence when it's an
action worth deliberating you don't tend
to struggle with self-doubt when i
picking avocados out of the market that
was that one ripe enough I think I'd
better go back now some of you some of
you may okay some because you're OCD so
this segment isn't not for you you
should go touch every northern facing
corner of your house right now while
avoiding all the tile correct otherwise
your family will die but for the rest of
us that trepidation that self-doubt it
only comes into play when we're nearing
the perimeter of something that matters
especially if it's your purpose and
we've talked about this talked about
living your purpose talking about
fulfilling your purpose because everyone
has something that they're great at and
so the lie that we tell young kids and I
hear it so often it's so prevail
so that you don't even think about it
you know some of us don't even think to
go on a second is that true just like
you're perfect the way you want well we
know that's a lie
no one's perfect and it's bad to tell
people that they're perfect you can
accomplish anything if you believe in
yourself the most important thing is
that you believe in yourself the lie and
that's a lie that we tell young kids it
teaches them to avoid one of life's most
fulfilling endeavors which is conquering
self-doubt to achieve one's purpose or
goal and I wish I could say you know on
a personal level I wish I could say that
I always believed in myself life would
be a lot easier it's not true constantly
had self doubts by black self belief
constantly have thought of myself as
under-qualified undeserving overwhelmed
I still do
by the way struggle with it every single
day but it doesn't stop me from doing
what it is that I know needs to be done
there's no shame we talked about this
this idea of shame and culture but the
problem is we want to praise the wrong
things and remove shame from things that
maybe should be shamed
there should be no shame and self-doubt
there's no virtue and absolute
unfettered self-confidence there's no
shame and self-doubt whatsoever just is
there is no sin in fear I'm gonna go a
little bit a little bit theological on
you here we've often heard I had a
pastor I've talked about this who who
once taught that fear is the opposite of
love it's not hate it's fear to be fair
it might have been Rob Bell I have no
idea could be a hairdo but we're taught
this a lot that you shouldn't fear the
stupidest thing I've ever heard in my
life so let's you even if you don't
believe I'm a Christian I make make no
bones about it but let's just say you
think it's a you think it's an Aesop
fable okay
Jesus was sinless otherwise there's no
point to the story that's the whole idea
behind the Christ have you read about
Jesus in the garden before the
crucifixion he asked God if there was
any other way any other way for this to
occur to please let this cup pass from
him that was fear but there wasn't
another way and so he took that hard
path just the same see self-doubt fear
how you feel it doesn't determine your
actions and your actions determine who
you are your actions are what define you
how even go as far as to say that the
most people with the most absolute
self-confidence tend to be buffoons and
the greatest folks to have done anything
they're chosen and ever they almost all
have a healthy level of self-doubt do me
a favor actually let's do this little
thought exercise here I want you to
think of a historical figure who you
really respect you admire even even a
great athlete i jus want you to picture
someone in your mind someone who's the
greatest who ever done X okay take a
second pause if you have to do you have
it okay now I want you to go research
that person find some interviews or find
some candid writing about how they felt
before some of their greatest
accomplishments a Winston Churchill
could be Abe Lincoln Marcus Aurelius
could be George st. Pierre could be
Richard Pryor every single one of them
without exception struggled with
self-doubt every single one of the
greatest to have ever done X or Y or Z
was nervous and struggled with
self-doubt they didn't walk on stage
whether it be the global stage the
comedy stage or the arena like some pink
song who thinks that they are perfect
the way they are and that they had
absolute self-confidence now on the
flipside think of the buffoons think of
the people you don't necessarily have a
ton of respect right like the cast of
Jersey Shore c-level actors the mediocre
plus-size Instagram models a guy you
knew from high school who's still living
in a senior think of anyone who you you
wouldn't want to emulate they tend not
all of them they tend to be the people
who have ultimate self confidence and
this unwavering self belief doubt never
even enters into the equation why is
that who would you rather be so the
final exercise I want you to do this
week it's just a mindful is just about
being mindful I want you to think about
what it is that gives you self debt what
is it that you would like to accomplish
but maybe you're not sure if you can or
maybe if you can't think of it I want
you to be hyper vigilant in just
throughout the entire week be as aware
as you can hyper vigilant this entire
week so that any situation that arises
as you approach it and if you get that
when you get that little feeling that
voice in your head telling you I don't I
don't know I don't think you can do it
is that voice popping up because you're
coming close to fulfilling your purpose
I want you to ask yourself is that voice
coming up because this is important this
is of consequence this involves your
life's potential have you been avoiding
it because it might sting you've been
cutting that feeling that voice
soif avoiding i want you to be honest
with yourself here's that you don't have
to believe in yourself
. you don't i think it's foolish to self
doubt is normal it's healthy you just
don't have to let it bad are you into
self defeat and all of this starts with
living and truth not your truth but
truth i'll see you next week
[Music]